there are people who were like you know
get a tattoo on like their forearm and
like are like I have to see this every
day for the rest of my life like I'm
freaking out I woke up with these
tattoos this is get cake dot young I
woke up with it I had no idea I had even
got it I was so [ __ ] up I literally
was just like all right that's their got
the name little peep because since I was
small baby my mom has called me beep I
don't know why people
Pete just it's just what she calls me
pretty much every one of my life calls
me peeps
I was born on Halloween night November
1st so I got the eleven one also so I
got like bats over here this pumpkin one
I got a lot of spooky [ __ ] going on
these things
I [ __ ] hate these things centipedes
they just seem to find me and like
bother me all the time so I figured I'd
get one tattooed on me I did not always
know I was gonna get tattoos the first
one I got is this big one right here
it's my mom's birthday and her initials
so that she wouldn't get mad at me this
is my first tattoo house 14 you got what
grandpa I got my mom I got friend
attitude on me so yeah I have a weird
you know definition of family it's not
the same as everyone else's like I got
my son right here on my leg but my son
is a doll that I bought at a store and
his name is meat I bought me a year ago
now with my ex-girlfriend and he's our
son and so I decided I had to give that
to you oh so this is my relationship
with my mom I'm Lisa is screaming mom
you know because whenever something's
going wrong in my life I'm freaking out
I call my mom on the phone I stressed
her the [ __ ] out underneath here says
Hellboy that's my first mixtape that
really caught people's attention and it
was very important to me I read the hell
of a comics and [ __ ] but I just love him
as a character and I love the whole like
idea of Ron I think that movie is very
underrated
I got the Pink Panther actually I'd
stayed up all night on mushrooms it's
not my best friend we took it over to
Venice Beach and I was like dude what
could I do just to make this like worse
and I went into a random tattoo shop I
got this Pink Panther at home sick
tattooed on me right here in my fingers
because I travel a lot you know I was
musician and I'm 20 years old so I'm
still young and I'm still it's my mommy
at certain times I'm from Long Island
New York fashion isn't it is there it's
just does isn't a thing so that's pretty
much where I got my style people would
always copy what I did in high school
and [ __ ] you know try to dress like me
and whatnot and it really pissed me off
so I kept changing there almost isn't
style because it's just me you know what
I mean if I'm feeling really Punk like
it's like [ __ ] everything I'll get it
weird red anarchy logo on my face or
[ __ ] this mood tattoo I don't think
there's really one particular style but
if I had to choose my favorite it would
probably be like cholo style tattoos I
for sure
2015 I got this broken heart right my I
was not feeling to it - well I'm very
just like out going with it it was kind
of like a push for myself to let he's
successful with like the music I was
doing because it can make it harder to
get a job when you have interfaces
covered in tattoos this is a lucky charm
it's just a horseshoe it's just for good
luck wasn't really well sometimes you
know it already drew this in London for
like an exhibition and I decided that I
would get it tattooed on me in London as
well
right after I shaved my head that one
really didn't hurt as much as this one
which I just really recently got my hair
still kind of [ __ ] up from it it's
like towards the back of your head more
and like the front of your head really
is not that bad but the further it gets
towards the back just like whoa
[Music]
now my tattoos have kind of become a
part of me and when I look in the mirror
I just see my face literally when you
get it it takes about a week to sink in
and then you're like this is just part
of me there are people who are like you
know get a tattoo on like their forearm
and like are like I have to see this
every day for the rest of my life but
I'm freaking out and I'm like dude I
have I woke up with these tattoos this
says get cake die young I woke up with
that I had no idea it even got it I was
so [ __ ] up I literally was just like
alright that's there this is one of my
favorites this is just my mood I turn a
mood it's really low quality but that's
because my mood is low quality you know
anything most people who were to get
this but this is like one of my favorite
tests so I found myself complaining a
lot being very ungrateful for the things
that have in my life and so I got the
crybaby tattoo on my face to remind me
that I have a really good and there's a
lot of people in her booth but you know
love to be in the position I'm in so it
just keeps me really grateful
[Music]
I plan on going from my feet covering
all the way everything as much as I can
without it like really hurting you know
what I mean I don't have any like secure
plans I just come up with tattoos like
I'll wake up I bet you all want to get
tatted today I kind of like looking like
a mess and just like what the [ __ ] if
you're thinking about it do it and if
you like how people look when they're
all covered in tattoos and you should be
covered in tattoos
wake up every day and like look in the
mirror and be like holy [ __ ] this is
this is sick if I woke up and I didn't
have any of my tattoos on I would try
for like an hour
yep so pretty much these are all the
stupid crazy tattoos I got on my body
and imma go get a bunch more real soon
and then come back and show you